would you allow scientists to expose you
to the novel coronavirus if it would
speed up vaccine development
nearly 40 000 people from more than 160
countries have signed up to express
interest in doing just that as the world
waits for the results of traditional
vaccine trials
in which participants come into contact
with the virus naturally
human challenge trials would
deliberately expose a much smaller
sample of young healthy volunteers
potentially cutting the study time by
several months but this approach is
controversial among some public health
officials and bioethicists because it
would allow participants to put their
own health at risk without a foolproof
rescue therapy
and this debate relates to a
long-standing divide over whether people
in low-risk groups
should be allowed to jeopardize their
own health to save the lives of others
and even get paid for doing so to save
one day
you know to me ethically that's a that's
a no-brainer josh morrison is a
34-year-old former corporate lawyer who
founded the non-profit one day sooner to
advocate for human challenge trials
if this approach speeds up the
availability of a vaccine even by a
single day
morrison argues it's worth pursuing if
you're moving the calendar forward by a
day
we think that about 4 500 wives around
the world is a reasonable
starting point and that obviously
doesn't include things like
the economic activity or the the
secondary consequences
um you know the kids who can go back to
school and the other illnesses and
people who are who are dying of those
because hospitals are
not able to treat them morrison got
involved with challenge trials through
his work trying to solve the kidney
shortage
he founded the non-profit weightless
zero after donating a kidney himself to
a stranger in 2011.
when the coronavirus pandemic started
morrison recognized the parallels
between challenge trials and kidney
donations
they're both ways for healthy volunteers
to accept a small amount of risk
to save the lives of the more vulnerable
it's definitely a thing with real risks
at the same time we let people do things
that are uncertain
all the time and what people take you
know the the risks to health care
workers
um during coronavirus uh were uncertain
and still to some extent are uncertain
to the best of our our knowledge
with available data those risks are
going to be lower
than other risks we let people take like
childbirth for example or kidney
donation
it's not just a matter of well we think
the benefits exceed the risks
and it's also not just a matter of well
it's the person's own choice i think
it's i think that you need to hit both
of those bars
but dr anthony fauci of the white house
coronavirus task force indicated in july
that the government has no plans to
encourage or move forward with its own
challenge studies
since the current infection rate in the
u.s is high enough to conduct
traditional trials quickly
morrison says this view is short-sighted
since challenge studies could still
speed the development of multiple second
generation vaccines that would be safer
more effective
and easier to distribute around the
world than the first ones approved
he also thinks u.s officials shouldn't
be counting on high infection rates to
continue as an american i think it would
be a shame to just assume
that people are going to keep getting
infected at the rate they're getting
infected now
and that we can't accomplish what the
rest of the developed world has
accomplished
um so i think that saying you know oh
well we don't need challenge studies
because
we're pretty sure there's gonna be a lot
of transmission and a lot of people in
america are gonna get sick and die
i think that to me seems misguided
better to have it and not
need it than need it and not have it
conducting a challenge trial also
requires fda approval but an official at
the agency said in july that this
approach could cause
quote ethical heartburn because if
something bad happens
you don't have a perfect fix for it
economists are accustomed to thinking
about trade-offs
it appears that at least in some parts
of the ethics community they are not
dr alvin roth is a stanford economist
who studies repugnant transactions
or exchanges that many people don't
think others should be allowed to make
he's one of 15 nobel laureates who
signed an open letter published by one
day sooner urging the national
institutes of health to prepare for
challenge trials
roth analogizes allowing well-informed
individuals to get infected with the
coronavirus
to letting firefighters run into a
burning building if you just wait till
it burns itself
out you put lots of people at risk and
so we pay firemen
to take additional risk to go into the
building
he points out that traditional vaccine
trials carry their own risks
unlike in challenge trials participants
don't have the benefit of constant
medical evaluation and first-rate care
and in a normal trial thousands of
participants get a placebo
meaning they can both get infected and
infect other people
they may even engage in riskier
behaviors if they think they've been
vaccinated
challenge trials particularly when there
are multiple vaccines to be tested you
can have
the different vaccines be the conditions
of the experiment
instead of saying some people get the
vaccine and some people don't
you can say some people get vaccine a
and some people get vaccine b
roth received his nobel prize in 2012 in
part for his work applying market
principles to kidney donations
it's illegal to pay donors in the u.s so
he came up with ways of encouraging them
without direct compensation by using
roth's insights policymakers were able
to increase
living donations by around 20 percent
but tens of thousands of people still
die
each year in the us due to the kidney
shortage and roth says that pain donors
could save many more lives
though some fear that with this approach
poor or desperate people would be taken
advantage of
we pay people to become firemen who
would not become
firemen if we didn't pay we should think
about how to be appropriately grateful
so that we're not
exploiting the people who give us these
things we need i don't think that we
feel that we're exploiting our
firefighters public service
is something we do compensate people for
and we do want to treat people well
and i think that is the commonality
between kidney donation and being a
challenge volunteer
is this idea of public service where a
lot of people see this
idea of compensation and they think that
it's inherently
exploitative and that it's treating
people as lesser
but it's actually the other way around
with the world on hold waiting for
results
thousands dying every day and hundreds
of millions at risk of injury or poverty
from the global pandemic
researchers at oxford university who
were the first to enter traditional
human trials with the vaccine have had
trouble recruiting enough participants
who are likely to become infected as the
natural virus transmission rate in the
uk has fallen
they are currently racing to prepare a
protocol for challenge trials that can
pass muster with oxford's ethical review
board with the aim of beginning them by
the end of the year
i'm confident it will be approved yes in
the u.s
reuters reported in mid-august that
partly due to the public pressure
applied by one day sooner
government scientists were just starting
to prepare a protocol for challenge
trials
two months after the nih first said it
would start that process
but the agency still has not committed
to moving forward with challenge trials
and private efforts to develop a vaccine
are following the government's lead
it's certainly ethical to move forward
and allow people
like myself and the other people who
work one day sooner who
want to take this risk and make the
sacrifice to be able to do so